bonjour merci bonjour merci d'être avec
nous alors justement on a beaucoup parlé
du renseignement à quel point c'est
nécessaire d'avoir un renseignement
efficace pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
c'est prévu c'est primordial d'avoir du
renseignement afin de prendre les
mesures pour contrecarrer ces ces
attentats en revanche on peut avoir les
meilleurs enseignements du monde des
personnes qui passent en effet des
radars c'est c'est très difficile de les
stopper en amont
ça fait des pas mal d'années que
j'explique ce qu'il ya ce qui est
important aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir des
primes aux intervenants capable de de
limiter les commandes de la ville est
victime des primes aux intervenants
comme certains pays le font on a remis
des dessins des cons dirais-je des
sociétés privées de sécurité qui sont
armés et qu'ils sont disposés un peu
partout sur les sur les sur les
monuments sur les églises sur les
cinémas restaurants de façon à être prêt
à intervenir s'il ya des attentats
aujourd'hui enfin depuis des années on
n'est pas loin ou dépendants de 300
morts en france et on a du mal au fond
on déjoue beaucoup d'attentats c'est sûr
en revanche des personnages qui passent
à l'action comme ça qui sont absolument
pas ficher les c'est le seul moyen de
restaurer cd stopper quand il passe à
l'action et d'avoir quelqu'un qui soit à
proximité immédiate de cette action-là
mais cet attentat là pour le stopper et
limiter le nombre de victimes c'est la
seule solution aujourd'hui faut prendre
il faut prendre exemple sur sur israël
qui a toujours des attentats notamment
au couteau ou à la voiture bélier en
revanche il y a désormais un petit peu
partout dans les villes et ils sont
prêts à à stopper ou à limiter les
victimes lors des attentats
messieurs martin et donc à vous
préconisez des agents de force de
l'ordre déployés un peu partout sur le
territoire notamment à côté des écoles
et des lieux de culte
alors aujourd'hui je suis bien placé
pour en parler si je vis à londres
j'ai une société
anglaise donc j'ai rien à gagner en
france jeudi jusqu'à aujourd'hui il est
il est plus qu urgent d'avoir une vraie
complémentarité entre le public et le
privé notamment il ya certaines sociétés
privées qui sont déjà armés qui ont déjà
l'autorisation d'avoir des agents armés
alors c'est pas n'importe quel agent ce
sont la plupart du temps des anciens
militants la police et policiers ou des
forces spéciales qui sont formés il n'y
a pas de céder personnes qui ont eu
pendant une vingtaine d'années où dix 10
ans des armes et ils sont très ils sont
très capables de de les porter aussi
dans le privé ce que je dis ce que je
dis depuis pas mal d'années depuis
beaucoup d'années depuis au moins dix
ans sait qu'il est important d'avoir une
complémentarité entre les deux jeux le
privé ne va pas remplacer les forces de
l'ordre il ya bien évidemment
en revanche il va il va délester les
forces de l'ordre qui ont d'autres pas
de choses à faire 4 comme on dit dans le
jargon qui sont des plantes devant des
monuments quoi mais aujourd'hui il est
urgent de le faire quoi monsieur bellamy
au niveau du renforcement de la sécurité
emmanuel macron l'annoncé 1,3 milliard
7000 militaires déployés dans le cadre
de l'opération sentinelle est ce que nos
forces de l'ordre à l'heure actuelle
soit assez préparés à la menace
terroriste vit encore avec nous est
monsieur martinez vous êtes un ancien
agent du service action de la dgse une
seule devant une question comment on
priorise cette lutte contre le
terrorisme alors moi je voudrais ajouter
quelque chose par rapport à ce qui a été
dit précédemment c'est que on pourra pas
lutter contre ce terrorisme là le
terrorisme islamiste si on s'attaque pas
en priorité numéro un à l'idéologie qui
aliment ses attentes à la jusqu'à
présent tous les gouvernements qui se
sont succédés en france je sais de quoi
je parle parce que dans les années 90
fin 90 on surveillait déjà des réseaux
terroristes islamistes en europe surtout
en europe à londres et sa une à une
c'est ce que d'augmenter depuis ces
années là aujourd'hui il ya une
vingtaine de groupes islamistes armés
sur sur la planète qui est qu'ils sont
capables de nous imposer leur idéologie
par la violence de façon locale
régionale nationale ou internationale ce
qui est la priorité numéro un
aujourd'hui c'est de stopper cette
idéologie là
pour lutter contre le duo l'idéologie en
france notamment on a une arme absolue
qui s'appelle la laïcité et il est
important aujourd'hui de remettre le
religieux dans la sphère du privé
comment comment procès ça va être
compliqué ça va être long il va y avoir
beaucoup de travail pédagogique à faire
mais si on s'y attelle dès maintenant si
on si on prône si on ne lance bien le
comment dirais-je à l'ennemi qui n'est
pas seulement l'islamisme qui est
surtout l'idéologie qui a débuté en 1928
avec la création des frères musulmans
il ya également le salafisme donc pour
moi il est primordial de déclarer le
salafisme criminelle et aussi les frères
musulmans comme un groupe terroriste
donc à partir de là on peut commencer à
remettre le religieux dans la sphère du
privé comme en en refusant toute
revendication religieuse du quotidien
qui fait partie intégrale qui font
partie intégrale du projet de façon à
imposer cette idéologie non pas par la
violence mais pas là comment dirais-je
parle là par la revendication
quotidienne qui va nous faire renoncer à
noa noa notre laïcité et ils vont
s'insérer dans les interstices de sept
de nos neuf de nos deux notes de nos
démocraties pour pour sa pose et il ya
également le financement et il ya
également les actions violentes des
actions violentes ont lu on les traite
on les traite notamment à l'étranger on
les traite sur le territoire national
mais toutes ces actions violent qu elles
sont alimentées par une seule chose par
cette idéologie qui est mortifère et qui
depuis des années n'a de cesse que de
d'alimenter c'est vraiment le carburant
de toutes ces terroristes abysses tant
qu'on n'aura pas compris il faut stopper
cette idée originale on aura tout des
des attentats en france on aura toujours
cette lutte entre deux blocs aujourd'hui
il faut reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui il ya
deux blocs qui s'affrontent d'un côté il
ya les islamistes pas écouté il ya les
démocraties notamment la france et
l'europe parce que c'est leur terrain
c'est leur terrain de prédilection
l'europe c'est le ventre mou c'est les
démons de la mode de la démocratie
européenne est totalement submergés est
totalement incapable de faire face à ces
revendications du quotidien l'angleterre
c'est c'est terminé la belgique n'est
pas loin aujourd'hui on est dans un état
lamentable
monsieur martinez
si en tout cas d'avoir été en direct
avec nous je rappelais plus être ancien
agent du service action de la dgse